un signe de la main et chargé de sens
devant se tord voir forcer
une cinquantaine de civils dont des
enfants ont pu quitter le complexe
d'azov talent vers ce refuge temporaire
ici on s'attend à accueillir encore
d'autres bus en provenance de la syrie
bombardé ou d'autres civils sont
toujours terré
ces évacuations se déroule au moment où
marioupol tram toujours
les bombardements continus signe que la
trêve pour permettre l'évacuation des
civils n'est pas respectée
les gens sont évacués autant que nous le
pouvons a dit que le président ukrainien
volodimir lnsq jauge prévient que tout
pourparlers diplomatiques sera avorté si
la russie tuent des gens qui peuvent
être échangés comme des prisonniers de
guerre ou libérés en tant que civil il
fait lourd constat de marioupol qui est
passé de ceux ci à cette ville
complètement détruite
dans ce tout refuge la guerre se termine
pour ce soldat ukrainien blessé par un
tir de char capturés et pu détenus par
les forces russes pendant 17 jours il a
ensuite été échangé compteur soldats du
camp adverse ils pensaient que j'étais
un des leur dit il ils m'ont demandé et
tu avec nous et j'ai répondu que je ne
sais plus ce que ce terme signifie
pendant ce temps les forces russes
poursuivent leur offensive sur marion
paul selon les autorités ukrainiennes
l'ennemi a repris ses opérations visant
à prendre le contrôle de l'usiné
et cela au moment où un convoi de l'onu
est attendue pour évacuer les derniers
civils réfugiés dans l'oubli au total
près de 500 personnes ont pu être
évacuées ces derniers jours de la ville
assiégée de mario pole ici daniel k jaws
radio canada montréal